I kind of weirdly want people to pull  over right now I really you know if you  give if you get letters or calls that  people got into accidents that's on you  guys I'm leaving all my liability I want  you to pull over I want you to look at  that mirror rear view mirror right  that's let's go thank you I want you  look at it you need to understand if you  look at it it's your fault what if you  know everything in life is on you right  it's not your dad's fault who was a  drinker it's not your boyfriend that you  know cheated on you it's not your  girlfriend who's always putting you down  it is your fundamental fault  the second you make that decision then  you can go on the offense  [Music]